bismillah al hamdulillah assalamu
alaykum which is a greeting of peace
peace be unto you thank you for tuning
in to another episode of the Dean show
we are here trying to help you
understand Islam and Muslims now my next
guest who is coming out in a minute he's
been with us before he has a special
section at the Dean show calm you can
hear his story on how he embraced Islam
amongst of the top topics that we've
done with him now we are going to be
talking about muslims in america
american history with muslims now just
to note we're going to be using the word
islam by now many viewers who've been
with us you know what this word means
simply surrender submission obedience
doing all this sincerely to the one God
the one God who created the Sun the moon
and everything in this universe and
that's easily summed up with one word in
Arabic which is a snob and a Muslim is
one who does this action the action of
submitting and surrendering sincerely
being obedient to the one God who
created everything in this universe it's
much easier summed up one word Muslim
how long have these Muslims who
implement Islam been in America and
that's what our next guests dr. Gerald
Dirks is going to help answer when we
come back here in the den show you don't
want to go nowhere
Allah there's only one word Muhammad is
His Messenger a la la la
ha there's only one but Jesus was his
messenger Allah no I did that maybe it
maybe it's just to break the ice
assalamu alaikum peace on the mercy of
God be upon you and you too my brother
how are you good good it's good to have
you with us here in dential we covered
quite a few topics with you before for
those of our viewers who don't know who
you are just take a minute and tell us a
little bit about yourself well I
converted to Islam in 1993 did the Hajj
pilgrimage in 1999 prior to that I'd
practice for a number of years as a
psychotherapist I have a doctorate in
clinical psychology but before that I
was an ordained minister of the united
methodist church having received a
Master of Divinity degree from Harvard
Divinity School did christopher Columbus
discover America or the Muslim discover
America that's hot let's talk about this
history with Muslims in America well
it's kind of ironic to say someone
discovered America when American Indians
were already here but this issue of
Muslims in American history is a very
important issue and what why is it so
important well let me illustrate it with
the story it was a year before 911 yes
and my wife and I were standing at our
local Midwestern Airport located right
on the buckle of the Bible Belt waiting
for our luggage to come down the
conveyor belt and a gentleman across the
way oh maybe 20 feet 30 feet away having
a glance over and he saw my long unruly
beard and he saw my wife wearing her
scarf and her long outer garment and he
did sort of a double take I noticed out
of the corner of my eye and then over
the course of the next five minutes he
sort of slowly meandered across the
space until he was standing right next
to me and at that point he turned to me
and he said where are you from
and I said well I'm from 35 miles north
of the air and he said no no no no no I
mean who are you from originally and i
said well i was born in 30 miles north
of here and at that sort of a puzzled
confused look crossed his face and he
started to turn and walk away and then
you could just see the light bulb going
on over his head and he turned back to
me with this look of triumph on his face
pointed to my wife had said well where
she from and I said well you know she
was born 40 miles north in here you see
what he was trying to do brother he had
correctly identified as as being some
Muslims and because he had made that
identification he was going to rob us of
our American identity and our American
heritage and in doing so he was
reflecting a myth that is very very
common amongst the American public and
that is that Muslims came first to
America in the latter half of the 20th
century that somehow Muslims are
johnny-come-lately on the American see
the truth of the matter however is far
far different than that we Muslims have
been here long before the latter half of
the 20th century we Muslims help tame
and settle the American Wild West and
the latter half of the 19th century we
Muslims fought to preserve the Union and
the Americans of a war between 1861 and
1865 we Muslims stood armed and ready to
defend the American coastline from
british invasion in the war of 1812 we
muslims fought to secure american
independence from great britain during
the American Revolutionary War we
Muslims built the agricultural base of
the American South long before there
ever was a united states of america we
muslims were here in the early part of
the 17th century in the british
colony at Jamestown we Muslims were here
in the latter part of the 16th century
in the Spanish colonies we Muslims were
here with the Spanish conquistadors in
the early part of the 1500s we Muslims
were here with Columbus in 1492 and yes
we Muslims even though this is a little
controversial we Muslims were here long
before Christopher Columbus ever thought
of coming to America amazing tell us now
I want to just go backwards at the
airport you were doing nothing minding
your own business but was it because now
we see a lot of Muslims and we addressed
this in previous shows the beard so you
had the you said the rouille beer there
long unruly beard and now your wife
wearing the scarf which if you look back
a with the beard in any picture that is
betrayed of supposedly Jesus he has a
beer doesn't he and most of them
pictures of him is a youth obviously do
not or most of even if you look at the
Ten Commandments with Moses he had a
beer didn't he well that's how artists
how they try to say yeah representing
and if you look back to some of the
modest women if you look at who
supposedly Jesus's mother what they have
portrayed of her in the picture you will
see her wearing the headscarf sure sure
many of the righteous woman you'll see
them preserving their modesty wearing
this and that's all that's correct you
know so this is just amazing now tell us
continue on how come most of us we don't
really get to know this this is a shock
to a lot of people that are listening
you know why is this well it's because
knowledge is so compartmentalized unless
you've read Arabic or have access to
someone who reads Arabic and you go back
to these very early Arabic books you
won't find this information but if you
do go back and you read Arabic or have
access to someone who reads Arabic you
go back to these early books you find
that there were a number of voyages from
the Muslim world to the Americas long
before Columbus in fact the earliest of
these wish cash cash even se deben oz
wat who sailed from Muslim
andalusia was now Spain Portugal in the
year 889 600 years before Columbus
sailing west across the Atlantic
discovering a new land apparently
islands of the Caribbean and sailing
back to Andalusia about a hundred years
later eben Farouk in the year 999 made a
similar voyage from Muslim Andalusia to
the new world you said eben what does
that mean for a son of some yeah summer
Farouk son of farooque that would be his
father okay yeah and then al idrisi
famous Muslim geographer and scientific
advisors to the King of Sicily in the
12th century wrote about a group of
eight Muslim sailors that sailed west
across the Atlantic from Muslim
Andalusia or Spain Portugal arrived at
two new islands but hitherto unknown to
them and there they were captured by
American Indians and held captive for a
few days and after two or three days
another Indian came who served his
translator between the Indians and these
Muslims from Andalusia and he arranged
for their release and they went back to
Andalusia now the important thing in
this story is to stop and think for a
moment wait a minute there's an American
Indian who can serve as translator
there's an American Indian who has had
enough contact with Muslims that he can
speak Arabic and serve as a translator
so we had these stories from written in
very early Arabic books detailing these
three voyages from Muslim Andalusia but
it's not just for Muslim Andalusia it's
also from what today we call Morocco for
example shaziadeen alia bem feito almaza
ronde sailed west from morocco across
the atlantic in the year 1291 reached
the new world
and perhaps the most impressive of all
is sailing from West Africa the Mandinka
kingdom of mally around the Year 1310
the sole Tanner King of that Empire
named Abu Bakar II sent two expeditions
west across the Atlantic now Columbus
sailed in 1492 of three ships the Nina
the Pinta and the Santa Maria from what
is documented in the ancient Arabic
books Abu Bakar ESET two fleets which
together totaled 2,200 ships so this was
a huge amount of men moving west across
the Atlantic and we know they reached
the Americas they never returned but we
know they reached the Americas because
there is a South American Indian tribe
which even to today uses Mandinka
ideograms as their form of written
communication there's a North American
Indian tribe whose syllabus of words was
written down by a Moravian missionary in
the mid-1700s and when modern linguists
look at that syllabus they discovered a
large number of those words or man day
the language of the Mandinka of western
africa so they obviously made it to the
Americas explored parts of South America
North America intermarried with the
American Indian tribes and gradually
their history was lost but they were
here and they were here almost two
centuries before Columbus so yes we
Muslims were here before Columbus you
mentioned that if you don't have access
to some of the Arabic books on history
or do you find this in some of the
history writings here in America like
when you were attending University at
Harvard will you see this information
there no no the sort of information
again is too compartmentalized uh-huh
people who are writing about American
history typically don't read Arabic yeah
the person who did the pioneering work
on Muslims in America before
this was dr. Abdullah Hakim quick yeah
who is fluent in Arabic and who has a
PhD in history by the way so he went and
looked at this authentic information and
this was documented and now anybody who
is this a sincere historian now he can
take from this work that he's done yeah
it's it's beginning to receive some
business okay so let's go back to what
we said why is this so important to say
for the Muslim youth to know this
history crucial for the Muslim youth to
know this or not even just a Muslim you
for Americans in general crucial for
them to realize that Muslims have been
here all along and the Muslims have made
contributions to America all along but
especially for the second generation of
Muslims in America this is a most
important piece of information because
as they hit adolescence they're
struggling to develop their own sense of
identity establishing their national
cultural identity as Americans and
establishing their religious identity as
Muslims and when you meet or confronted
by this sort of bias that says well if
you're Muslim you obviously can't be an
American yeah that creates conflict for
them that creates identity conflict for
them so it's important that they have
this grounding and understanding their
own unique heritage in America that
Muslims centuries before them were
contributing to America tell us some
more interesting things that we probably
didn't hear before about some of the
other contributions that Muslims have
made to America well as i mentioned
muslims were here with columbus it has
epic voyage in nineteen and 1492 amongst
them we can point to at least one muslim
who was Pedro Alonso Nina he was a
Muslim from Africa sailed with Columbus
and helped charter and navigate much of
the Atlantic Ocean but three very
important people we need to point out
are the pins own brothers and the pins
own brothers were mariscos now that's a
term that needs some definition those
people probably you're not familiar with
that term
and 1492 the Spanish Inquisition was
going on full blast and the Spanish
Inquisition targeted both Jews and
Muslims for their persecution let's stop
for their and digress what was this
about this Spanish Inquisition Justin
short Ferdinand and Isabella you have
their Catholic Majesty's of Spain hadri
conquered Spain from the Muslims with a
fall of Granada and 1492 and they had
received a special bull what's the
technical term from the Pope to launch
the Spanish Inquisition to force people
to convert to Christianity both Jews and
Muslims a lot of torture went on a lot
of people were killed in the process of
doing this both Jews and Muslims at that
time the Muslims in Andalusia or Spain
received a religious verdict from
scholars in North Africa that said look
if your life is threatened go ahead and
undergo a sham conversion to
Christianity and on the outward side
appear to be Christian just continue to
practice your slummin this is if you're
at the sword yeah after neck and if your
life is threatened so a number of
Muslims did this and these Muslims who
did this in their descendants were known
as mariscos so we had the three pins own
brothers with Columbus their mariscos
now the three brothers had very
important positions in Columbus's
expedition Martin pins own was the
captain of the Pinta one of the three
ships his brother Vicente was captain of
Vanina the second of the three ships and
Francisco was the pilot of the Pinta so
three key positions in Columbus's staff
were held by mariscos people who had
either undergone a sham conversion or
were the descendants of people who had
undergone the sham conversion to
Christianity but continued to maintain
their Islam and private in addition one
sailor that sailed with Columbus on 14
d to Rodrigo de triana who was a
Christian when he made the voyage as
soon as he got back to Spain he actually
converted to Islam which took a
tremendous amount of courage because the
Spanish Inquisition like I say was going
full tilt and persecuting Muslims and
Jews so these are the people we know of
it sailed with Columbus and helped
Columbus quote-unquote discover America
mm-hmm please keep keep on going we
really intrigued by this information
well and after Columbus we had Muslims
coming with the Spanish conquistadors
because again that Spanish Inquisition
was still going on and many many Muslims
volunteered to go to the new world as a
way of escaping the Spanish Inquisition
so for example we have Muslims in almost
every one of the Spanish expeditions to
the New World by the conquistadors new
flow do llano was a Muslim who
accompanied Balboa in his expedition of
the Americas but probably the most
famous of these Muslims with the Spanish
conquistadors was esta vaniqa of as amor
that's how you'll find his name written
in the history books and he is famous
Spanish language films have been made
about esta vinico of azimuth sir he was
a Muslim his real name was Mustafa's
amore esta vinico of as amor was a slave
name he had been captured in Morocco and
enslaved and in the year 15 27 he sailed
with his owner from Spain to the
Caribbean and landed in Hispaniola and
there he and his owner joined the DNR
vaise expedition that sailed from
Hispaniola in the Caribbean to Florida
and this expedition consisted of five
ships in about 500 to 600 men well along
route they were hit by a hurricane some
of the ships sank the survivors when
they made it to Florida were immediately
attacked by Indians many of them
perishing those survivors including
Mustafa
began a 5,000 mile westward and then
southern Trek on foot from Florida to
Mexico City and they were the first
people from the old world to go through
you know Georgia and Alabama and
Mississippi and Louisiana and then down
into Texas and finally down into Mexico
and to Mexico City and when they finally
arrived there there was only Mustafa and
three others still left a lie out of
those 500 to 600 who had begun an
expedition history books talk about him
but they all talk about him as esta
vinico of as amor they won't mention
that his real name was Mustafa samuri
and they won't mention the fact that he
was a Muslim yeah what about cutan Kunta
Kinte well this is later yeah he
obviously wasn't there with
conquistadors but before we get to the
conquistadors or I get to come take
empty you know Muslims were here with
with the early colonies the Spanish
established a colony early on at Santa
alena back in the year 1566 and many of
the colonists that they took we're from
the Galician mountain areas of Spain and
Portugal which was an area that was very
very densely populated by Muslim so it's
a very safe assumption we had a number
of Muslims in the Santa Elena colony
which was located in the southeastern
what is now the United States we also
know that Spain settled Turkish Muslims
both in Cuba and Mexico and in the
southwestern United States these were
primarily Turkish Muslims who were silk
and textile workers and in Jamestown
Colony that the British established
again we had Turkish Muslims who were
brought into the colony again primarily
silk and textile workers and in fact
they became so numerous and Jamestown
Colony that Virginia actually passed a
law prohibiting any more Turks of Muslim
from entering the Jamestown Colony and
the first written record we have of
those Muslims being there is from the
Year 1631 so again very substantial
contributions you mentioned kunta kinte
yes very famous when alex haley's book
roots yeah they should have a new
revised DVD or movie that one can see I
watch them do that and the the
miniseries that was the miniseries past
years ago really doesn't mention the
fact that he's it was a Muslim mm-hmm if
you are a Muslim and you know what to
look for you can deduce it but the book
makes very very clear that kunte kinte
was a Muslim in the Americas both north
and south america during this
unforgivable period of human slavery
there were approximately 20 million
enslaved Africans that were brought to
the Americas of these current historians
are now estimating between twenty and
thirty percent more Muslims mm-hmm so
between four and six million enslaved
African Muslims were brought to the
Americas many of them highly educated
some with the equivalent of PhD degrees
from the University of Timbuktu and
historians are now finding in little
county museums in the American South
entire books written in Arabic by these
enslaved African Muslims Wow the entire
Quran written from memory in Arabic
entire books of Islamic jurisprudence
written from memory in Arabic so a very
educated group of people and some modern
historians are now positing that the
percentage of literacy among the
enslaved Africans in the American South
was actually higher than the percentage
of literacy among the slave owners it's
just that the slaves literacy was in
Arabic not in English yeah so who worth
some of these Muslim slaves one was
contact Kinte yes and Kunte Kente grew
up in ladies born around 1750
anja for in West Africa and what is now
Gambia when he was a teenager he went
out to into the jungle to get some wood
to make a drum and at that point he was
captured and enslaved taken to the coast
and put on board a ship the Lord
Ligonier and transported to the Americas
and how horrible these conditions were
on the ship these people were chained in
a reclining position where they were
lying down body next to body and kept in
this position throughout almost the
entire voyage how long would a voyage
take oh it could take a couple of months
and they were given you know a bare
minimum food and water the conditions
sanitary conditions as you can imagine
we're horrible or no bathroom breaks you
know you just stayed in that position
how bad was it well on the ship that
kunte kinte came over on we're told that
approximately thirty percent of those
enslaved Africans died during the voyage
to the Americas well cuz they can't they
reached the Americas and was sold at
auction to john walker or waller of
spotsylvania county and could they can't
they could not adjust to being a slave
and so he repeatedly tried to escape and
finally to prevent him from escaping
anymore waller headed one of his feet
amputated mm-hmm and at that point then
he was sold to Wohlers brother who was a
more somewhat more compassionate slave
owner he later married father to
daughter named Kizzy who was sold away
from the family to another owner that
honor raped kissing producing a son
called Chicken George and there's a
photograph of Chicken George take a late
in his life as an old man that shows him
sitting down and he's wearing the cufi
the skullcap associated with the Muslim
and the thobe or long gown associated
with Muslim men so we know kunte kinte
was able to pass along at least some of
his aslam to his
daughter and she interned some of it to
her son hmm so cut they can't they
probably the most famous of the enslaved
African Muslims in America though in my
book Muslims in American history i give
the biographies I think of about 30 of
these enslaved African Muslims so made
it to the United so which one your books
is this the one that people now who
really want to know more about Muslims
in America they can find that history
here in your book Muslims in American
history you forgot or forgotten ugga see
us okay yeah so and they can see this
book at dirks online books dirts online
books com yes okay and amongst other
books you have written how many books
total six and then I wrote five chapters
at a seventh book yeah if you can give
some the audience some closing remarks
regarding the conclusion of this topic
and some advices and they can also learn
more yeah there's a lot more to be said
about America Muslims an American
history we've only just started
scratching the history of the earliest
part of that history yet to be said is
the the Muslims who fought in the
American Revolutionary War the war of
1812 the American Civil War and those
who helps tame and settle the American
Wild West so there's a very rich rich
history here of Muslims in America
contributing to America and that goes
back centuries so there there is a
long-standing Muslim American heritage
that people do need to be aware we
didn't just arrived yesterday we did
we've been here all along and I'm sure
there's many others who maybe had
interaction with Muslims who because
like we said a Muslim is one who makes a
conscious decision to surrender submit
to the one God and agree that Muhammad
was the last and final messenger sent to
mankind that's correct then confirming
Jesus as a messenger Abraham Moses and
all the other messengers that's right
it's something very simple thank you for
being a project like thank you for
tuning in to another episode of the Dean
show you can learn more muslims in
america the history
legacy and you can go to our brothers
website that's Dirk's online books to
read more on this topic I hope that you
got to benefit and learn something new
and we will hopefully see you again next
week here on the Dean show until then
assalamu alaikum peace be unto you the
dvds for Dawa as allah has said in the
Quran in surah now 16 125 will do elasa
be laid up bookable hikmah to invite all
to the way of your lord with wisdom
beautiful preaching and reason with them
in ways that are best and this is a
great opportunity for you to take up the
obligation take up the call as allah has
told you to do and share this beautiful
message with the world islam submission
to the one god come and see what
everyone's talking about if you find one
contradiction it can't be from God but
the rational idea the rational
explanation is you do your best give up
for spring guide is why I will never
give up spending this message hope there
you take that necessary step you don't
know if you're going to live till
tomorrow
so you got to find that urgency to do
the right thing right now if you say
that you're not believing Jesus you have
stepped outside of this nun you cannot
be a Muslim and attended our faith too
it's cold it's Leigh everybody sleeping
I arise and ask a lot of thinking me
Omar you see hola you know all the sins
I do I turn to you to figure my sing
tomorrow I'm you seem for slave you're
my love alone I'm the one runs away all
the guide me